and too often now white people are being
judged by the color of their skin and
that is wrong and that is I'm often
commenting about that on Twitter which
is why I then get a bunch of racists
following me because they think AHA it's
a line she's on our side
[Music]
hello welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kisser
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people as you can see today we're on
location in a secret location and our
guest a returning guest for the third
time today is the headmistress of the
Michaela school Katherine bubbles sing
welcome to chicken entree hi thanks for
having me it's great to have you here
let me set the context very briefly for
why we're having this conversation
because we spoke to you only a couple of
months ago yeah and it's unusual for us
to come back to the same guest but is
that we've talked with you about
education a lot yeah today we wanted to
talk about something that we never
talked about in society nowadays which
is of course races right that never gets
talked about but the reason is you know
this controversy with David Starkey
happened you had some interesting
thoughts about it Francis and I have
talked about it on live streams and and
got a lot of hate from every side for
trying to just work out what we think
about it yeah and you and I were having
a very interesting conversation on
Twitter where you were saying that you
thought that not only was this comment
that David and we'll get into what it
was made was racist but actually he has
a history of making these comments yeah
and then you add it to that quite
unusually that you quite like David at
the same time and I just think that's
such a weird thing to even be able to
say in modern society so just give us
your summary of what you thought you
know David made this comment maybe
remind everybody what it was yeah what
he had said in the past and what your
take on this whole situation yeah well
David's talk he has made many racist
comments over the years uh you know
we're talking more than a decade that I
know of his racist comments but
presumably there have been others before
that and I think actually part of the
reason why he's so bold is because he's
managed to get away with these kind of
comments for so many years and as I said
I quite like David Starkey you know he's
a funny guy he's so eccentric and I've
met him and he's very entertaining and I
know
that's odd to say because people sort of
think but if you're racist then you you
must you know you're the worst person in
the world you know you're Hitler is how
we think and the thing about the word
racism is that it really just spam it
you know people right from you know the
little old lady who clutches her bag
when a few young black boys you know go
by to Hitler and then there's everything
in between
and you know I would even go as far as
to say that everybody you know that you
know that Avenue Q song you know
everyone's a little bit racist sometimes
you know like I kind of say that is the
case I would say stark he's a step above
that though he's not just everybody's a
little bit racist and um in most most
recently the things he said I mean I
actually went throughout a little list
here of stuff in interview with Darren
Grimes that that he said I mean the main
thing was there's so many damn blacks in
Africa you know on earth I mean it's
just the fact that he said that the damn
blacks in Africa but I mean the the
contempt with which he says it you can
see it on his face
um no I know some people will say oh but
you know how do you make that judgment
well you know what if he just said that
one comment and that was it then maybe
you might give him the benefit of the
doubt but this has been happening for
years I mean and also throughout the
thing I mean other things he said and he
said well we think of a slavery as a
terrible disease when in fact and I
thought sorry but what slavery is a good
thing I mean this is what he you know he
says he talks about blacks and their
lifestyle and their music and their
dress like well do I have this livestock
do i word listen to this music and dress
like that I mean I think I'm certainly
not pulling my trousers down and bopping
along as Starkey woods would seem fit to
cut to describe me he talks about he did
that about statues hmm he's dismissive
of statues coming down which you know I
don't agree with statues coming down but
his dismissal of them he says well
slavery was not the equivalent to the
Holocaust alright what so that's why
slight touches shouldn't come down I
mean he's so lazy
in his intellectual thought when it
comes to race so lazy and this is a man
who's extremely intelligent very good
with words and when people say to me oh
but he just slipped up in his speech no
David Starkey doesn't slip up okay this
is a man who's very eloquent and he
knows what he's saying and he's allowing
himself to be lazy in these spheres
because he doesn't care and he doesn't
think it's important enough to get it
right he also talks about how well
slavery is done now
it was it was 200 years ago so we don't
we don't need to discuss it now because
it's all done well actually slavery was
only just finished we only just finished
paying off for it you know for the
slavers who were paid off we've only
just in the last couple of years
finished paying paying them so the fact
is slavery isn't done now
I happen to be against reparations for
slavery I'm against the statues coming
down but David stocky is a racist now
things that he said in the past on
Newsnight in 2010 he talked about how
the whites have become black and what he
meant by that actually coming back to
the lifestyle and the dress of black
people he was meaning that um there is a
culture among some white young people to
copy kind of gangster american-style rap
artists and so on well that's there's a
very different thing from saying they
become black what are these white chavs
as he called them are they are they
copying me I don't think they are but
he's unable to make that distinction and
I found it very interesting on Twitter
because when people would try and defend
him and I was horrified by the number of
people who were defending David's talkie
a number of my own followers I might add
and I think it's because a number of
people follow me who don't see these
issues because I often defend white
people against racism against white
people and because I'm critical of that
they see me as being on their side when
I'm most definitely not on their side
I'm on the side of the truth and what
else has he said oh he said that David
Lammy sounds white now how does David
Lammy sound white I mean what is it what
is it to sound he-man is educated that's
exactly what he's well-spoken he's
educated well so for sake you.your when
you're white you're well-spoken when
you're black you you know you dress in a
certain way you you're a gangster
essentially it's beyond a shadow
out the David Starkey's racist now that
doesn't mean he's Hitler I don't think
he's going around committing hate crimes
uh-huh but I do think he's a racist and
that's when the conversation then gets
interesting about you know what do you
do with that and so on but for me it is
perfectly obvious that he's a racist he
twists every time he talks about black
people he twists his face and this kind
of just this this way as if he's kind of
horrified you know um
in the way that I do when I'm talking
about racism and uh and he's never
stopped and people have pulled him up on
this time and time again they pulled him
up on it for the Lamy comment with the
whites become black comment and he's
never changed and so you know I'm a
great I'm a headmistress I'm a teacher
at heart and I always believe in giving
people a second chance um that's what
you do with the kids you know you say
well look this is how you got it wrong
let's do it again
you know stocky has never never accepted
that opportunity in fact he's just got
worse and worse over time and so it is
hard to then think what do you do I
don't believe in canceled culture I had
to say well let's just pause it Francis
with his slightly points I'm talking
about reminding me of racism that he
talks about Churchill
and how and how complex a man he was and
people often accused her chill of being
a racist for the Bengal famine because
he he ensured that the food that was on
its way to to them
weary rooted and be brought to the
soldiers and that was a very difficult
decision and one might say yes he
decided partly because he believed that
Indians were inferior and he did but he
was also trying to win a war so I kind
of I want to give the guy some slack I
get it you know he says this about
Churchill and says that Churchill
thought that Indians could not govern
themselves which he you got to be a bit
of a racist to think that you think
people can't govern themselves well
stock he goes on to agree with charge
Churchill he says well I mean well the
only reason why they could afterwards
was because we British had been in
charge for so long in the first place
well I mean now I can forgive Churchill
because he was a man of his time Starkey
is here right now in 2020 saying that
and I have a problem with that and I
think it's quite right that we should
call it out we ought to and and the
worst of that whole thing was Darrin
Grimes at the end saying and what should
we conservatives do because we
conservatives need to fight back and I
was thinking wait a minute I would
consider myself to be a conservative
certainly a small C conservative I'm not
a big C but I'm a small C conservative I
don't agree with David Starkey and I
know a whole load of other conservatives
who wouldn't agree and it is it is
really worrying when we equate those
kind of antiquated and racist views with
conservatism because they really have
nothing to do with each other and that's
why you should always watch trigonometry
not Darrin Grimes and you mentioned that
he's a man of great intellect he's very
interesting it is he has a lot to offer
Society and a lot to offer our culture
what do you do with someone like that
when they have views that you've
described as races do we just put them
away and then forget about them or or do
we try and rehabilitate them it's a very
difficult question rehabilitation is a
good is a good one you know um what I'm
always doing on Twitter when I'm talking
to people I'm always trying and
sometimes I can get a bit annoyed but I
try and keep it under control and I'm
always trying to explain things to
people so that over time they can come
to see oh well maybe actually I might
reconsider my views on that and so I was
doing that a lot over the Starkey thing
and I was trying to explain to people
why he was racist and and I think some
people took onboard luck a lot of what I
was saying I think others didn't but
perhaps next time they will um I did
notice that a lot of people would try
and defend him by saying he'd said
something else other than what he'd said
no nobody said that the blacks that the
whites were taking on American gang
culture no no actually he said they'd
become black and so because they like
Starkey they wanted to defend him now
the thing about racism it's kind of like
people make the mistake in thinking with
right and left they think there's kind
of a line and they think that the
lefties of
good people and the righties are the bad
people and there's this line when in
fact it's a circle that goes like that
and the extreme left and the extreme
right meet each other there yeah I would
say the same thing comes for the line
that people think exists between the
woke and the the racists so there's the
woke in the anti-racists over here and
so you might put an Tifa right at the
end there and then you've got the the
races over here and I wouldn't put
Starkey right at the end you know I'd
put put the National Front right right
but it's not like a line it's a circle
and so the National Front meets up with
an Tifa down here and the woke I would
say are down here and I think that
they're pretty racist too and the David
Starkey types over here as well I think
they're pretty racist and ultimately
what is racism
so racism as I keep trying to explain on
my on my Twitter feed is when you aren't
unable to look at somebody and just
treat them as a human being you judge
them by the color of their skin and what
I mean by that is oh I don't know ah
when I used to live in France people
would tell me to go back to Algeria so
they just look at me and think oh she's
obviously from Algeria of course I've
never been to Algeria but and they would
tell me to go back there that's pretty
obvious um but then there are other
times where people ask me to be part of
a group or on a board or something and
then they'll say well we want you to be
there because you you're you'll take the
diversity box and I think well you know
I'm really skilled I do what I do in
education I think it's pretty amazing
you know and I've set up a school and
there aren't that many people who have
had the kind of obstacles that I've had
to overcome in order to achieve what
we've achieved here at Michaela and yet
the reason you want me is because I take
your diversity box now what my colour
does at that moment is it prevents them
from seeing me as a person they can't
see my accomplishments they can't see me
for who I am all they can see is my
colour that is racism now the people who
are doing that are on the left okay
so they've come on the circle this way
the David's talkies of the world who
think oh well she's black so she must
listen to certain types of music he's on
that side so um it's the joy
of somebody according to the color of
their skin and not being able to see
past that and of course because color is
is a big part of somebody you see it
right away so you know you're unlikely
to look at somebody's eye color
you know you won't catch that as quickly
but color is hard to not see so you see
that right away and so it is good I
think to talk about race and to talk
about these things to make people aware
now I know some of my Twitter followers
be horrified to hear me say this you
know the idea of unconscious bias and so
on there's a lot of truth in the
unconscious bias at point that the left
always put forward or that the woke put
forward
um and what they mean by that is that
people make subconscious decisions all
the time about others without sort of
realizing what they're thinking about
other people and unless you question
that about yourself and think hmm well
is it that I always hire men and never
really think about women or I imagine
that men are stronger when I say
stronger I don't mean physically I just
mean better leaders or or more in
control and that's an assumption of mine
maybe I should think about that because
you know what I might be missing out on
some great candidates when I'm hiring
them who are women who I want to employ
similarly with black people you know
there are all sorts of ideas and
stereotypes and and people then think oh
but stereotypes are okay well no they're
not that is racism that's what racism is
now the problem we've currently got is
that if you're considered to be racist
people don't go where everyone's a
little bit racist they don't do that
they say cancelled you got to lose your
job you got to lose your family you got
to lose everybody I'm so of course
everybody's then running around on
eggshells going oh my goodness I'm not
racist I'm not racist and I'm that's
really unhealthy and so you know if I
was talking to black friends I would be
saying I'm not sure I'm not sure it's it
what we want is to kind of browbeat
white people into feeling so
uncomfortable about race that they never
say anything they never think anything
and they're just worried all the time
you know don't we want to have
conversations and and and hear what they
have to say and then if we're constantly
beating people over the head all you do
is make people
quiet and and then they're really
uncomfortable so so yeah so coming back
to that point about Starkey what do we
do
the difficulty with Starkey is that he
is in a position of authority in a
university and he is teaching young
people and that is difficult because I
there's no question in my head that a
man like that should not be teaching in
a school I don't think so because I do
think he's a racist and I don't think
he's willing to change because many
people over years have challenged him on
this and he hasn't been willing to do
that
having said that he needs to be given
the opportunity to do so and I think
this would have come as quite a shock to
him because he's got away with it for so
long there are such things as you know
suspensions disciplinary areas you know
you have a conversation you you know
there's a lot of in between before just
you know firing somebody um I do think
we need to have some sort of standards
for people especially in education
because they've got a really important
and sensitive role in in in developing
young people I do think at University
look the universities are so woke that
the young people there could probably
argue stalking into the ground so I'm
not sure they need protecting so much
you know but I don't think it's a
straightforward as some people on the
right feel which is that they just
should be absolute freedom for everyone
to say whatever they want you know I
mean it was interesting I put it on my
Twitter feed and I said well should we
allow Holocaust deniers on TV every
night should they be out there just
saying that the Holocaust never happened
and I had somebody tweet me you know an
article well obviously the Holocaust
didn't happen welcome to Twitter you
know the thing is is that the assumption
is when people say yes but we just need
to let everybody say whatever they want
and we'll the truth will come out and I
think that's because we're in 2020 that
we feel so secure in saying that because
the assumption is well obviously we
wouldn't we wouldn't take on racist
views obviously we wouldn't all start
denying the Holocaust but history has
shown that people can be very sheep like
and they can just follow somebody who
has a lot of charisma somebody who's
well SPO
okay you know and so you know there's a
reason why Germany it's illegal to deny
the Holocaust in Germany there's a
reason for that and I get it now it's
not illegal in this country but um we
would not we wouldn't put holocaust
deniers on television we wouldn't give a
massive voice and that's the thing about
Starkey he's got a big voice you know
he's art he's being interviewed he's on
TV do we want that there's a difference
between cancelling somebody and making a
decision of you know what they're just
too contentious to put on television in
terms of the things that they're saying
now I know what people will say to me at
that point they'll say but who decides
who decides who gets who we don't do
that with and who well who decides right
now we don't put Holocaust deniers on so
somebody is deciding that I'm not quite
sure who is I mean maybe it's just I
don't know the general public and what
they will put up with um yeah I I also
think that um people one of the reasons
why the country feels so under siege and
I understand I also feel under siege at
the moment and I do think there is a
culture war and I mean the irony of this
is you know I'm going on about Starkey
being racist but I'm I really am on the
other side of the cultural or you know
as you know we've had many conversations
you know I consider myself to be a small
C conservative but Starkey is definitely
a racist and the the we need to have her
we need to have discussions we do need
to be open about these things but
they're what Twitter has shown me is
that there are quite a lot of white
people out there who refuse to have the
discussion you know I'll tweet about
Peter fryers he's an author he wrote a
historian he wrote a book in the nine
1984 called staying power the history of
black people in Britain and it gives you
loads of facts about black people in
Britain and I tweeted this a number of
times think I'll read this you know hey
everybody if you want to know in its
really big book you want to know more
about black people in Britain why don't
you read this and then you'll be more
informed I would get tweets back saying
thank you I'm educated enough mmm and I
think you've made this point cash and I
think it's a very valid point that if
you keep if the invitation to educate
yourself doesn't come from people like
you but it comes from
the woke camp who are saying if you
don't agree with me it's because you're
a bigger here's 50 books like white
fragility that you must read yes people
will become resistant yes and I think
that's a big part of yes but let me let
me come back to David because we've had
David on the show yeah I know I'll be
honest I was not aware of the news night
comments I was less political at the
time right but we spent an hour with him
then we weren't for dinner he was not a
culet yeah telogen he agreed with many
other things you said about jean-jacques
rousseau yeah stock you and I agree on
lots of stuff right absolutely which is
which is why we're having this
conversation yeah you're someone with a
very nuanced and sensible view of these
things he never in our conversations
that anything that was in any way
inappropriate no opinion he didn't make
any racist comments yeah he was a lovely
guy he was charming he was funny as you
say Yeah right so I guess the question
for me is well what do we do now you
know you talk about this guy shouldn't
be on shouldn't be perhaps on television
as much or at all right so if you if
you're opposed to cancel culture how do
we how do we how do we do it do we have
him back to talk about what he said yeah
do we never talk to him again maybe yeah
you have him back and you see whether or
not I'm always want to give people but
then we're racist but then we're racist
right I mean we're already oh I don't
think so I think I would want to talk to
Starkey I would want to stay look can't
you see how you say things can't you see
how it comes across can't you see like
look this is how if you wanted to say
you could have had an interesting
discussion with Darren Grimes about
whether or not slavery was genocide you
could have given the definition of
during the genocide and said that you
think that it means that you need to
have had the intention to wipe a certain
people out and to be so lazy in your
thing in your speech there's so many
damn after black people in Africa I mean
you know and so dismissive like who are
these people you know would you yeah did
you really think that's what he meant
because this is the counter-argument
that was hoping Francis would put
forward team
he chickened out so let me put this to
you right when he was talking about that
my initial perception and I'm just
putting it out I'm not saying this is
true I'm just saying that was my initial
perception with it his exasperation was
at what he perceived to be the stupidity
of the counter-argument in other words
he wasn't talking the use of the word
damned was not he didn't mean it to be
about the black people he meant it to be
about the stupidity of the argument that
he was countering yeah that is an odd
thing seeing as his interviewer was so
sick of antic that he even described
himself as being a dick off' and he
wasn't arguing with somebody and getting
heated in the moment and getting really
angry because the other person was being
unreasonable he was just he had the
platform you could say whatever he liked
he was in total support with the person
who was interviewing him it makes no
sense the idea that he would be so
frustrated and there's a whole series of
things that he then says in the
interview was I've been through and
things that he said in the past that
Lamy sounds white you can't get round
that one you know and so all the people
who are trying to explain away well he
must have meant this he must have meant
that what over the last decade he's been
he must have met x y&z I mean the fact
is the man is very lazy when it comes to
his language around black people and
that's because he doesn't think black
people deserve that attention he doesn't
think that it matters what he says he
thinks he can get away with being rude
racist and obnoxious and it doesn't
matter and I'd love to say that to him
you know I wouldn't be rude about it and
I'd be a lot less kind of heated than I
am right now um I'd want to show him and
explain it to him because I'd really
hoped that he'd come round to me what I
think is the right way of thinking maybe
we should get you boys here well I'd be
more than happy to talk to him and try
and persuade him I really would and
that's because I don't believe in
canceled culture and I don't believe in
in giving up on people you know and that
is because I'm a teacher I never give up
on any kid you know you always keep
trying because there's always you just
always gonna keep trying it and it's the
same thing now for me because I'm intend
to be fighting the woke and tend to be
fighting the left because I believe in
traditional education I believe in
standing at the front I believe in
holding children to account I believe in
discipline all of these things for some
reason on the Left they just abandon all
these ideas god only knows why and I'm
always trying to explain to them via
Twitter and via the talks I give
conversations with you all of this stuff
about why it is that more small see
conservative thinking is is what we need
to do and I've done that for some time
and what I find really often either via
DM on Twitter or when I go to an event
people come up to me quietly whisper to
me I really like what you're saying and
I'm gonna tell me their name they
quietly come and tell me or they'll say
I didn't like you a few years ago and I
really didn't believe what you were
saying but I can see it now I've been
following you on Twitter and I can see
it I see what you're saying it's just
taken me a few years people can change
their minds I changed my mind
you know I used to be a real lefty
teacher I used to be I used to think
like a typical lefty teacher you know
the reason why schools are failing as
there wasn't enough money black boys
weren't achieving because of
institutionalized racism I mean a whole
variety of things that I thought I
changed my mind over years and that was
the experience of teaching that taught
me to change my mind but also the fact
that I'm just open-minded there are a
lot more open-minded people out there
than we realize and there are of course
the extremes and I've met them both on
my Twitter because uh there and I you
know more recently with Stocki I met my
right-wing followers who were just
digging their heels in and saying no you
know people are saying me well obviously
we're not racist we follow you do you
follow a black person on Twitter and
that means you're not racist I mean like
and then I come to realize in talking
with them and that's where it's really
interesting because I would never meet
these people normally and you know why
once many years ago met up with this
when I used to write my blog I used to
write blog called to miss would love and
and this was the day when there were no
blogs and there was this guy called BNP
member and he was a member of the
British National Party and he used to
come and in comment on my blog because
in those days Twitter didn't exist so if
you want to have a conversation you had
to do it via comments on the blog and
all these lefties would come on and
argue with him and and he would say
things and I always found him quite
interesting he was an intelligent kind
of self-taught guy white working-class
guy up in the north and um and then I
suggested to him and you know it'd be
really interesting to meet you I never
met a BNP member before and so I met up
with him and it was so fascinating
because he arrived and he was hobbling
along and I said oh you know he was in
the suit I mean you know I was in jeans
and I were and and uh and he said oh
yeah my feet hurt because the shoes are
new he had bought the suit and the shoes
to meet with me and he said well you
know I figured you went to Oxford
University so I needed to get dressed up
for the occasion
this was really weird you know at the
same time he was explaining to me about
his girlfriend and how he'd gone round
that morning to his girlfriend's house
and they have a little they had a little
toddler and he wanted to say hello to
his son and he didn't she wouldn't let
him hold the boy because she said you're
going to see that black woman you're
gonna contaminate him and so I'm not
letting you hold onto him so all I'm
saying is that racist complex you know
on the one hand this guy this is the
kind of guy he is and this is the
environment in which he mixes on the
other hand he's getting dressed up in a
suit and shoes that hurt his feet
because I've been to Oxford University
you know I I just always believed in
trying to keep an open mind and in
talking to people and uh and so the the
race thing you know it's um the other
thing that I wanted to talk to you about
was um with school and how we teach you
know because one of the big problems at
the moment I see on my Twitter feed a
lot of white people who are very worried
about what's gonna be taught at school
and they're what I mean I've spoken to
people I mean friends of mine and so on
who have said they're worried about the
black lives matter influence and what
you know work that's being sent home
that white kids have to interrogate
their whiteness and they need to talk to
their their parents about their
privilege and and what they do is white
people and and that it's dangerous stuff
and I do I worry about them and there's
something that we would never do here at
Michaela
I have to say most of our kids here are
ethic minorities but there are a few
white kids I would just never want to
divide the children in that way
children children and nowadays one of
the ways in which we have so advanced as
a country is that when I was a child at
school they talked about going to the
p-a-k-i shop and if I was in the room
they go troops sorry you know and it was
normal to call people names mmm nowadays
calling kids names a racist name in the
schoolyard it's the worst thing you can
do the kids would all jump on you
there's no way the kids will not
tolerate racism so just divide them up
according to race and make them see this
thing and that's the point about the
circle woke people are constantly
talking about race and constantly
defining us identity politics says that
a black boy cannot identify with
Shakespeare identity politics says that
black kids can't learn their French
verbs they need to learn French rap
instead that's why the worker racist
that position is racist and what is so
terrible is that these woke people think
not all of them I'm sure not all what
people think like that but some of them
they think that to be anti-racist is to
keep doing that and that is racist which
is why it's a circle the extreme right
say for instance that brown people black
people cannot be British the woke would
never want them to be British and in
schools one of the things that we do
here at school is that we talk about
being British all the time we're all
British together we have a British flag
flying pride outside we sing god save
the queen and Jerusalem I vow to thee my
country when England was playing in the
World Cup we had England flags
everywhere all I ever did was talk about
football I don't know anything but I
made sure I found out about football so
I can talk about it to the kids you know
now and that's because I want us all to
be British and and this is a really
important point which is that the
nation-state which the woke reject is
what binds us together and stops us from
being racist if you don't have the
nation state the nation state it's it's
it's
group of values it's our country we
believe in democracy we believe in the
rule of law we believe in the right to
be gay and not have policemen throw you
off the top of a building which will
happen in many countries around the
world right now our country stands for
something and we are British whether we
are white or black now the fact is that
too many people are ashamed of being
British so we reject the nation-state
when it's the one thing that stops us
from being tribal because if you get rid
of your nation-state then you have to
reduce to race and then you're white I'm
black and and and I'm gonna be with my
people and you're gonna be with your
people because we word we were or reduce
the tribes and that is how the one great
thing about the West is that nation
state well not the one great thing
there's loads of great things about the
West but one of the biggest great things
is that we have a nation of which which
which binds us together in terms of its
values but because too many British
people in particular white British
people I would add are so guilty because
of Britain the British you know history
of colonialism and slavery and so on
which sadly there are some people who
are quite proud of that and III do think
that we should be ashamed of that but
that doesn't mean that Britain do new
great things as well and and when we
teach our histories you see here at
Michaela we teach British history and we
teach British history the good and the
bad and we don't sit there and say white
people are good
black people are black people are bad
sorry black people are good and white
people are bad and we don't relate it to
the present so we don't say things like
look at how black people retreated
during slavery it's the same as what
happens now with racism we wouldn't do
that we teach British history and that's
because all of us have an entitlement to
be in tort British history so we can all
feel British now that includes slavery
that includes the Amritsar massacre in
India that includes Gandhi that includes
colonialism that includes the slave
Atlantic slave trade it also we would
also include civil rights and North
America because that helps to shape the
world that our children are growing up
in we also teach things that aren't
British so the French Revolution for
instance because again that's part of
Europe now all of that
helps to ground our children it if
ethnic minority children are constantly
told that they're not British by
well-meaning white people on what I mean
by that is they're well-meaning teachers
who are ashamed of being British so they
never talk about it or the media go on
about race all the time or who go on
about not being they don't celebrate
Britishness right they don't do that in
fact that minorities feel like they
don't belong to their own country if
they feel like the establishment is
against them whether or not it is that's
a different argument
they cannot succeed it's impossible to
succeed and it is our job as educators
to make children feel as if they belong
to their country and if we believed in
the nation state and in our values as
being British we wouldn't reduce
ourselves to tribalism but that is where
we have now reached and that is why the
woke are running around saying white
privilege black people are good need to
take down the statues and they've lost
their minds and they're just running
around they don't know what they're
doing and that isn't to say there aren't
racist people like David Starkey as an
example racist complex and um and our
culture sadly has just deteriorated to
this point because we have lost the
values of the nation-state and it's a
really powerful thing that you're
talking about but as someone who was a
former teacher I saw this coming into
education around about ten years ago
where so I attended for instance a
seminar on how to teach black boys and
how we have to expect different from
black boys and the thing that's really
racist about that is seeing black people
as this monolith when they've got all
right so we're talking about black but
what do you actually mean do you mean
West Africa do you mean Caribbean do you
mean Congo yeah all these different
things and which is exactly what Stocki
does yeah
but which is people from both sides do
that right so I guess my point is if
both sides do that how do we solve this
problem I don't know we do things like
this well that was great
[Laughter]
we talked about it this is actually the
first time I've been able to explain and
you know one of the reasons why I
thought this would be great you know to
try and explain in detail why I think
we've reached this point in this country
you know the two sides like I say to you
there are people on Twitter you know
racists I mean I just tell my favorite
Twitter followers I think some of you
are racists and they follow me if you
can't see that Starkey is racist I think
you've got a problem with race I really
do because the thing is you watch it and
you think oh well David lamby's sounds
white that's all right it doesn't jar
with you you don't know that's a bit
weird that's because you can't hear it
and you get they don't you don't hear it
because you yourself have similar
thoughts and that's why I think you
yourself are also racist I think that is
a little bit unfair because for example
I myself I watched strictly the Darren
Grimes yep just the clip yeah I was not
aware of anything David said previously
yes yes and I watched that clip and I
listened to her and I thought well I
know David as to the extent that I yes
he never said anything inappropriate
when we spent time with him I watched
this clip and I can see that maybe his
intent wasn't racist okay so it's a long
way college on why didn't you at that
point go I thought it was a very ill
judge cop yeah but but but okay I'll
tell you why but that's important okay
you immediately your reaction was oh yes
now you then tried to rationalize it
because you like it
so understand no I try to understand why
he may have made her well because you're
giving him the better for the damage yes
he does know and you're trying to
rationalize right because you're
thinking I like this guy he's a good guy
he can't possibly have meant that so
maybe he meant this and I totally
understand that and actually had it been
just one comment that he'd made I
probably would have done the same thing
it's the history and not just the
history but all the other stuff that he
says in the in the whole interview that
then makes me go look obviously this guy
has a problem what you did was naturally
he was and this is my point is when you
and I had a conversation about it you
quote I hate this word because it's
misused but you quite and quite educated
me if you like right you persuaded me by
giving me more information yeah so
that's why I think it's maybe not them
helpful thing to say if you can't hear
and then then you're thinking in racist
ways because I was just giving someone
the benefit of the doubt yeah yeah no I
mean once you've heard all of my
evidence oh sure right if you hear all
of this and are still saying no but
David Lammy does sound white then we've
got a problem but but you need to
remember that when I say that the
person's racist I don't mean their
Hitler mm-hmm I mean I think you're
racist I think you're probably a good
dad or a good mom and you a nice brother
and sister to somebody and you know I
like I'm not saying I'm not saying you
commit hate crimes and it's not what I'm
saying
hey but isn't that part of the problem
Katherine that and I don't use this term
right that we almost see if someone's a
racist it's a it's almost something a
pitiful it's like the worst yeah thing
you can be the moment listen somebody is
a racist they've always like well they
are the worst person in the world I know
I know and that's a real problem because
as I said at the beginning racist kind
of spans everything from the little old
lady who clutches her bag to Hitler and
obviously there's um there's a huge
number of things in between and and I
also do think I've new cue everyone's a
little bit racist you know and and it
isn't the end of the world but it is
good to talk about these things and the
reason why people get so angry about it
I suppose with racism is that it's not
something anyone can change you know
your race is is something that's what
you are and and you from the point of
view black people it the reason why that
book you know why I'm no longer talking
to white people about race which I tried
to read and actually couldn't breathe
because I found it so awful you know I'm
not a proponent for this you know I
don't but I do get the point
hmm it can get very frustrating as a
black person constantly explaining race
to white people because why people don't
have the experience of racism um they
can it's very hard to explain it and
then they don't necessarily understand
and then you go back and forth and when
I was younger I probably would have been
a lot more hot-headed and thought
preface you know you're just an idiot
white person and I'm not talking you
anymore
but you know I'm older now I am a
headmistress
I believe in talking to people um you
know a lot of these people are young and
they're hot-headed and I forgive them
for that because I was hot-headed too
when I was younger um it is it's hard to
it's it's hard to keep your cool
especially when you're talking to a
white person who is just refusing to
listen to you and refusing to recognize
that his or her experiences are not the
same as the black person's experiences
and you know I once gave a talk the
battle of ideas about white privilege I
believe white privilege exists but I
also believe that pretty privilege is
exists and tall privilege and firstborn
privilege there's all sorts of
privileges that we all have and we tend
to just talk about white privilege but
if you're the firstborn in you if you're
the only child you're super privileged
and you're far more likely to do well in
life if you're an only child then if
you're the fourth born um if you're
really attractive you're far more likely
if you're ugly or however many more
times likely to go to jail you know like
there there are all sorts of privileges
that one has in life but people tend to
take the opinion of either you really
believe in white privilege or there's no
such thing as white privilege well
actually there is it's just that there's
a middle way and I'm always trying to
say on Twitter there is a middle way um
you can believe it's Talkies racist but
also believe that he shouldn't be
cancelled in the way that he was that
there should be a conversation um it's
just that nobody allows these
conversations to take place because they
just go BAM and then that's you know
that's it for whoever it is well we're
having it now so let's make a talk about
this right see for me why privilege is
is that it's more nuanced even than you
are talking about because I think I
would certainly acknowledge there in
every society there is a majority
privilege the majority ethnic yeah
enjoys a certain level of privilege what
I find the concept of white privilege
quite insulting personally because a lot
of people would look at me and say that
I'm white but I've experienced plenty of
racism so when someone says well you're
white
therefore you have no idea about racism
well that's not accurate so I am then
being judged as a member of an ethnic
group by someone who's quite ignorant of
my background yes people who look like
me in Russia are called black yes and
treated right according
in this country people have been racing
I'm so that that to me is why why it's a
bit of a problem because it's used as a
wedge issue to drive people apart
whereas when it's used in a more
sensible way you talk about majority
privilege high privilege attractiveness
privilege you put it in that sort of
context then you're not saying to white
people you are you have some kind of
original sin that which you must
perpetually atone no that is the way
that it has which is where a lot of the
pushback in my opinion and a lot of
their resentment comes from yeah which
is where you then have people go I don't
have any privilege what you're talking
about yes right and I think this is why
you talk about the circle yeah right now
it seems to me like the work people have
are now driving quite a few people on
the other end further down towards the
racist right if you like exactly and
what we need to do is be at the top of
the circle that's where we should be
aiming to be you don't want to be woke
you don't want to be you know extreme
right or you know I'm well I would say
aunty Phi supposed to match up with the
extreme right here but the next step up
from that you don't want to be them you
want to be in the middle and that means
looking at every situation having a
nuanced conversation
the thing about racism is that it is it
is complex as an idea and and it
requires unpacking in the way that we're
doing now and you know it's really
interesting about your background I mean
I suppose what you're then saying is
that you're not really white and so
that's what you're saying
I don't you try to get rid of you for a
while now you're cancelled and then
you're saying well people have just
misunderstood that and that's fine I
mean what I'm really saying Katherine
and I think it is quite important is
that look you you you're mixed-race
yourself right I have friends who are we
have a friend who's from Barbados for
example and he's quite light-skinned and
he talks about well black people treat
me differently because my skin isn't
quite black enough there's all sorts of
so I did what I'm really saying is don't
judge me by my skin colour don't judge
me by who you think I am ask me what is
your experience well what
what has happened to you in your life
why do you think what you think yeah and
then let's have a conversation and you
know what you're saying there you're
saying please don't be racist right
that's what you're saying you're saying
treat me as a human being don't just
judge me on the color of my skin and too
often now white people are being judged
by the color of their skin and that is
wrong and that is I'm often commenting
about that on Twitter which is why I
then get a bunch of racists following me
because they think AHA it's a line she's
on our side
yeah and actually it's a circle and I'm
criticizing the people down here they're
just right next to them on the other
side over here on the circle isn't part
of the problem when it comes to white
privilege and something that I get quite
frustrated about is that people use
white privilege and they discuss it and
normally it's people from a very middle
class upper middle class background but
if you say to somebody who is white
working-class that they have privilege
well all of them really really struggle
that's gonna make them very very angry
it's something that we don't talk about
in this country which is class privilege
yeah well I mean I didn't I'm talk about
prissy but but the thing is is that if
you take a white working-class person
and then the black working class person
well the white working class person does
have white privilege in comparison to
the black working class person it but in
comparison to the white middle class
person obviously the middle class guy
has the class privilege I mean the thing
is is that I mean even doing it like
that this business you know why we're
all doing it it's because of the
victimhood
you know Olympics that we've got going
on which is that we have created a
culture where you are liked the more of
a victim you are and so everybody's
trying to hold on to as much victimhood
so even the royal family you know I mean
they're why they're pretty rich family
so then they start talking about mental
health because the only thing it's the
only card that they can play mental
health issues yeah yeah yeah we too are
victims and the reason why everybody's
having to grab on to whatever victim
card they can to be able to play is
because that is how our culture as a
society has become once upon a time you
want it to be the hardest-working you
wanted to be the guy who overcame every
obstacle and the one who provided for
your family and so on no more no you
want to be the guy who's the most
depressed and that is depressing that
our culture in our society now in
Britain is one where we are aiming for
the lowest denominator that's mad right
and um that's why we're having that
argument of well who's more oppressed is
it the white working-class guys the
white black working-class guy is it the
black middle-class guy I mean for
goodness sakes people need to pull
themselves together young people fought
me to hold you set up this school you
know you know how many people um you
know for three years I had to fight all
these people people used to have
placards out with Tory teacher written
on there
they sent me racist emails they used to
shout abuse at me I would have parents
evenings and they would they would they
would go in the parents evenings and
start screaming abuse they'd stand up
just to cancel me you know I have been
cancelled we talked about council
culture I lost I out of a job I was told
I would never work in the state sector
again now this is 2010 before I wasn't
on Twitter
there was a very small thing then so
people don't really remember
I got canceled I lost my whole
livelihood I lost everything I couldn't
work in the state sector I was told that
was it and it took me three years of
struggling struggling financially
struggling in terms of my health I got
very ill because I was attacked so often
the vitriol that came my way
why because I dared to stand up at the
Conservative Party conference and tell
the truth as I saw it which was that the
education system was broken now that's
crazy
but what I didn't do was sit around
licking my wounds saying oh I'm a victim
I'm a victim what I did is I picked
myself up every time I give an assembly
I say to the kids when they knock you
down you pick yourself up and you keep
on going because that's all I'm just
gonna do it's gonna keep knocking you
down and sometimes it's cuz you're black
sometimes because you're female
sometimes because it's you're gay
sometimes it's because your mother got
killed when you were six years old
sometimes it could be anything right hmm
it doesn't matter you're gonna have
obstacles doesn't matter what they are
you have got when with the kids here we
have got to instill a sense of
resilience in them so that they can
overcome those obstacles I'm what I
can't stand about the woke is all
they're ever doing is telling my kids
that they're oppressed telling my kids
that they can't make it in this world
telling them they don't belong in their
country which is to undermine all of my
work that is what I feel all the time I
feel so frustrated not why am i fighting
the woke all the time because they are
the number one people that stop my kids
from succeeding so you know stalky in
his racism I mean I do think he's a
racist and you will see me on Twitter
they're going at it telling everybody
how racist he is but he is not my worry
my biggest worry are the woke because of
what they're doing to my kids and they
don't realize it they think they're
doing good you know in Martin Luther
King's time it was easy to see Martin
Luther King good Klu Klux Klan bad you
know it was obvious now it's not so
obvious we've got the circle nobody
understands it nobody understands what
it is to be racist we've got people
campaigning to make sure that we're
teaching storm Z in music class instead
of Mozart oh great so my kids won't know
who Mozart is you know I once gave in to
something this was right at the
beginning when we open at the school and
I was showing them Beethoven's fifth and
I played it you know I wanted them to
know Beethoven I showed a picture of him
with his wig and then I said how
difficult it was for them growing up
nowadays because they don't come across
this kind of music and actually I was
talking also about the kind of awful
music they can come about where you know
women are shaking their booty and all
that kind of stuff and I was saying you
don't want to listen to that you want to
listen to Beethoven instead and I said
when I was growing up there was Kylie
Minogue Kylie Minogue was the worst that
there was you know then later at lunch I
was eating with them and it turned out
when I was talking to them they thought
the Beethoven and Kylie Minogue were
contemporary we don't realize how little
kids know in schools right right people
are saying oh well we were never told
about slavery listen they're talking
about decolonizing the curriculum what
I'm always saying to everybody is
there's no point in talking about the
curriculum when kids are leaping out the
window you know I want I say the leaping
out the window what I mean is the
behavior is so poor right or the
teaching methods are so poor that nobody
remembers anything that they've been
taught you know there is so much work to
do in our school system you want to know
what the solution is yazmin solution is
its goal its education why am I so
passionate about education because kids
are the future I mean and we have to
teach them properly but what are we now
doing is a knee-jerk reaction to black
lives matter where we're running around
telling white kids to interrogate
their whiteness I mean what kind of
insanity is that look we need to be
teaching a good history British British
history curriculum that's what we need
to be teaching we need to have
assemblies that make the feel kids feel
like they belong you know I would say to
everybody I'm going to show a brought it
so I could show our book the power of
culture it is all written by Micaela
teachers and it's written look you know
actually I got a bit here which I
thought I might read out from one of my
my head of history who says here there's
no reason why I medieval kingship cannot
be taught alongside the economic
revolution of the peasants revolt
because often the local one let's talk
about the peasants role don't teach some
kings and queens well why can't we teach
them both there's no reason why the
codebreakers at Bletchley Park during
the Second World War
cannot be taught alongside the tragic
story of Alan Turing why is it tragic
because Alan Turing he broke the enigma
code amazing he was gay because of the
time he ended up committing suicide you
know like you can teach both right you
don't just have to teach Britain is so
brilliant look we broke the Enigma code
and leave his life out you can also
include it right in fact a chronological
narrative of English and British history
does not make it harder to incorporate
the stories it makes it much easier but
you know what they teach in schools they
teach history through medicine in time
through crime I'm telling you look if I
went into detail on this about how
history is taught it is scandalous right
the reason why nobody knows anything is
because of the way we teach my mother
drink everybody is from Latin American
it does remind me of a very swollen
party when the wrong you make it very
good but but the question I wanted to
ask is it isn't it doesn't it come down
to with the way the woke and the way
they behave and victim that is that
isn't it just easier to be a victim
isn't it just easier to roll up and go
you know what I'm oppressed
you know what though if you what you
went through it would have been so much
easier to go you know what everyone's
against me everyone doesn't like me it's
because of my conservative leanings or
whatever else yeah I give up and the
entire system is against me then simply
going you know what I'm gonna fight
against it I'm go I've got these hurdles
but I'm gonna overcome them
whatever my hurdles might be mm-hmm yeah
yeah exactly
so it is easier what we always say to
the kids is think about what your legacy
is going to be when you're on your
deathbed when you look back at your life
what are you going to be able to say you
accomplished and do you really want to
look back and say well everybody was
racist so I couldn't possibly make
something of my life or everybody was
sexist so I couldn't do X Y and Zed or
do you want to be able to say there were
these obstacles and I overcame them and
I contributed right you people always
say well what makes you so passionate
about education because I want to be
able to lie on my deathbed and say I did
something I made the world into a better
place we teach the kids about personal
responsibility about duty you are
responsible for yourself you know I am
the master of my fate I am the captain
of my soul as we say all the time now
because you can make a difference and
change something in your life my whole
point of having a good school is to
enable children to change their stars
because if all schools are doing is just
enabling the working-class kids to just
end up doing whatever you know as they
would have done enabling middle-class
kids to take the jobs as the bankers and
the lawyers then we're not doing
anything I want to change things for
these kids or at least give them the
opportunity give them equality of
opportunity that is what we should be
doing in schools we shouldn't be going
around telling white kids to question
their privilege what we need to be doing
is giving them all a sense of
Britishness because they will then
naturally come to these things
themselves right they will question
their own privilege at some point or
they will question their own lack of
privilege because when you give kids
lots of knowledge and teach them Lots
and love them they are then able to run
with it people come here all the time we
get 600 visitors every year and they say
how come your kids are so inquisitive
how come they're still curious look at
all their hands up in the lessons how
come they are so resilient it's because
we teach them but
you have to believe in the basics of
really great discipline and great
teaching methods of standing at the
front and leading forward but over the
last 30 40 years we've lost that in
education and now we're talking about
decolonizing the curriculum it is not
about decolonizing curriculum it's about
getting good behavior in our schools but
I don't know nobody know I'm not gonna
say nobody listening they are listening
they are they're the silent majority I'm
absolutely convinced that the silent
majority course are on my side of course
there but Catherine speaking about
changing the world and people who have
you mentioned Martin Luther King our
Lena I want to come back to that because
I think it's it's important I've had
conversations in the last few days with
people where I was saying I feel like
we've moved away from his dream I feel
like we're not judging each other on the
content of our character and that
troubles me you know you talked about
identity politics it's exactly the
opposite of what he was talking about
and people legitimate I mean I'm not
making this up or say to me Martin
Luther King was a coconut people say
that yeah why yeah why was he was he was
not woke enough for them so he reached
levels of insanity right that I Martin
Luther King's getting cancelled next but
my question I'd looks that these people
are very stupid who say that but my
question to you would be did I mean
people yeah
sorry yeah he was selling out black
people but so meaning you've stayed your
audience meaning that he's white on the
inside and black on the outside yeah
that I get a lot you know right you are
a stranger but basically what what
they're really saying is his view that
we should treat people as individuals is
then sufficiently taking into account
structural issues bla bla bla bla bla
now do you think we just with society we
need to just go back to that or do you
think we need to incorporate some new
thing into that good question so like
the thing about structural racism
there's a difference between what I
would say systemic or structural racism
and institutionalized racism people tend
to use them in to talk yes change of me
I don't think they are what is
structural
systemic is what Martin Luther King I
mean these people are idiots that's what
he was fighting against right he was
fighting against racist laws yes and it
was it was lawful to divide the toilets
yes he was fighting against racist laws
we no longer have racist laws we have
the Equality Act we do not there is no
structural racism okay there just isn't
what people mean is that there's
institutional racism now institutional
racism is more of a cultural thing
cultural racism things so when people
ask me to do X Y & Z because like take a
diversity box I would say that was more
institutionalized it's not that there's
one individual who's a racist going I
hate you Katherine you're black or even
you know well actually I mean I suppose
they are seeing they aren't judging me
on my color but it's so
institutionalized they don't realize
that they're being racist that's what
institutional mean um you know I was
speaking about head of history this
morning actually about about Tudor times
in fact because of stark ekeus [ __ ]
there's a woman called Miranda Kaufman
who's written this book on black Tudors
because what people don't realize is
that there have been black people in
this country since Roman times now the
vast majority of them of course came in
the 1960s but there were a couple
hundred black people living here in the
Tudor times and it'd be good to include
that why not in in the teaching of
history uh
now David stocky actually refers to this
and universe for instance the John Blanc
who is this trumpeter for King Henry the
eighth and he's a black guy and I mean
he has access to the King I mean you
know and he dismisses it ah these people
and they're ridiculous nonsense about
this sort of stuff well why are you
dismissing this David Starkey it's of
interest isn't it interesting that there
were black people living here during
Tudor times and people don't realize I
mean I find that interesting
um the diversity aspect of Britain in
England over over I mean this is English
I mean John Blanc was it was English
it's very English I mean that's
something that black people probably
won't even say themselves now and yet
here's a black man King enemy the a and
yeah you know like it's amazing it
should be interesting and it should be
interesting to a historian like David
Starkey and yet he dismisses it right
now um stuff like that should be taught
alongside because otherwise
people leave school thinking that black
people only came to this country in the
1960s it's not true you want to teach
accurate history right so um but
Katherine come not to my point come back
to my point yes
well you love education and so you're
always keen to draw back but I want it
just broaden it a little bit so let's
just come back to Martin Luther King yes
is his vision which is judge people on
the content of their character enough
okay so what I would say is we have come
so far in terms of race Martin Luther
King would never have imagined us coming
this far he wouldn't have known what
that looked like so he was fighting
structural and systemic racism because
he was fighting the laws we now have the
Equality Act it is know that no longer
exist we have a kind of culture I do
think there is a cultural and
institutional racism that exists and we
can talk about that because the kind of
far-right racism of you know calling
somebody a name in the street and all
that it has nearly disappeared I mean
it's gone away I see nearly look I live
in London a guy on Twitter and an Indian
guy on Twitter the other day said look
I'd lost counting the number of times I
get called the pH the p-word you know so
I don't know I don't actually know what
it's like outside on the rest of Britain
I certainly know in London there's no
way that that sort of thing would happen
to me
and I have seen the change of things
over my lifetime and you know I can
remember the 80s was very different so
we have come so far that we can now talk
about racism which is just more when
they took about unconscious bias and all
that we're talking about more subtle
forms of racism which is why I don't
think we should be cancelling people
because gosh it's not the same kind of
racism is calling somebody the P word or
the n-word and so on
it's it's nuanced and it's and it's and
it's interesting and we should talk
about it and by talking about it we
change it but what happens because we've
got canceled culture everybody on the
other side then just says not talking
about it not interested and they shut
down and then the other side go and pull
statues down and then we just got this
race war and where the hell are we going
to go to from there but isn't part of
the problem as well that there's this
narrative which is that you know
we've never been more racist the
far-right are rising again they've
become ever more emboldened and all of a
sudden we saw you get both sides getting
aggravated at that and then you get the
woke of a saying right we need to rise
up we need to fight and then the other
side go well they've got too much power
this is ridiculous and we yeah it's a
it's a fight for power that's what it is
and um you know this whole situation
reminds me a bit of the kind of Israel
and Palestine you know neither side is
listening to each other and and and
you're right things get exaggerated and
I don't think that helps anybody um I
mean look I I wish we could bring some
forgiveness into this you know we've
lost sight of religion you know Jesus
believed in forgiveness
and people people make mistakes I think
we need to forgive you know in our own
lives we need to forgive you know
personal you know friends boyfriends
girlfriends all of that you need to
forgive but you also just in life you
know that's why I say I'd happily talk
to David Starkey because I would I
forgive you know and then you need to
forget you know and then you need to
move on but if you're gonna keep bashing
you know it it doesn't help anybody
and um yeah it's and then people go to
the extreme what I was gonna say about
John blank was that on the one hand we
want to teach that there are black
people in Tudor times but what you don't
want to do is go the other way
where are you teaching everybody all
about black tutors and you forget about
all the white ones and then and then
people come out thinking that Tudor
times were all black people generally
and and and and the white guilt thing is
highly problematic and I would say - I
mean that batter who say I don't want to
talk to white people but I suppose that
I'd say to white people
my advice is always you need to find a
black friend who isn't just bashing you
hmm who has some complex ideas around
race you know so I think about myself as
having complex and nuanced done and
understanding who can be critical of
racism but can also see that racism is
directed towards white people and if
you can find somebody like that then you
might be able to trust some of the
things that they tell you about the
racism that they experienced um and that
white people should try and get rid of
the guilt the guilt doesn't help anybody
um there's a great book by Jason Riley
and called
please stop helping us it's an he's an
African American and he um he's talking
to liberals and he lefty liberals and
he's saying look I know you're trying to
help us but you're really not helping us
you're hurting us and to all your kind
of Lefty doers I would say if you
haven't you thank you
we've got at least three sorry we
actually have most of our viewers
actually disaffected lefties oh okay
well I would say read that because well
you know he just explains why the the
the help isn't helping I would also be
aware I mean I hate saying all of this
cuz I sound like some you know like I'm
some arrogant twit saying white people
do what I say but anyway you know if you
feel really guilty and if you're so
worried about being a racist that what
you're doing is running around making it
look like you're non racist so you're
putting a black box up on Instagram or
you're putting a letter on your
corporate website we believe in black
lives matter like did you ever did you
know black lives matter before right you
just putting up now because you feel
pressure from society to do so you know
if if that's what you're doing
stop try and think how can you live a
good life you can give money to charity
you can go and work in a soup you know
kitchen you can go and become an
inner-city school teacher you can become
a social worker you can do all sorts of
things to make the world a better place
I have spent over twenty years working
with kids in the inner city I've
dedicated my life to education reform um
and I've taken a lot of flack for it
I've lost my livelihood and my my you
know the ability to work in the in the
world that I loved and then I had to
spend three years vitriol cutting my way
constantly you know I've done everything
I can and I know that I can sit on my
deathbed at the end of my life and look
back and say yeah I did something you
know that's what we should all be aiming
for don't worry about how you appear
right now forget about how you appear
you know I talk to you honestly just now
I just tell you everything I think I'm
not thinking gosh what do people think
of this
who's gonna hate me who's gonna like me
you know what I would say to everybody
who I'm talking to you know the white
people are rolling their eyes and saying
you know she's such a woke crazy person
or the other ones who say my god
she's so she's such a racist or whatever
look it's coming from a good place
you know it's coming from my heart I'm
trying to do what's right and um I'm
trying to hold the middle ground we all
need to head for the middle ground and
remember the circle that I spoke about
you don't want to be really woke and you
don't want to be really on the really
write you know you want to be somewhere
in between I'm a small C conservative
because I believe in personal
responsibility and duty and obligation
and tradition you can believe all those
things and still be an anti-racist you
know what Catherine on that note we're
out of time yeah it's great it's great
to chat with you and we always ask the
same question the angle she's you're
gonna run out there this being the third
time what is the one thing that we're
not talking about that we should be
talking about
and don't say education because we're
yeah no it's true well I hope after
people watch this video they might talk
about the circle idea that I'm saying
and that there is racism on both right
in the left I don't think we recognize
the racism on the left enough and we
don't talk about it enough and people
take refuge in the left because they
think that's what makes them not racist
or anti-racist and I want to push this
middle way that's where you can be an
anti racist by not being on either of
these sides that meet in the middle
perfect well thank you so much Catherine
if people want to follow you on twitter
you are at miss Snuffy so that's miss
with an underscore Snuffy big f and uff
wife thank you so much for coming it's
been a brilliant interview and thank you
so much for watching check in for
another live stream or another wonderful
episode and we'll see you very soon guys
see you very soon take care and don't
miss the live streams Tuesday Thursday
Friday and Saturday at 7 p.m.
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell buttons next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger pot and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word